oh yeah
and we're live
whoo once again
you know what
let's do it
oh wait
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your
[Music]
welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
back what's up y'all welcome back to
riffin with ribbons
all right on today's episode
i actually watched a ufc fight for the
first time it was paddy to batty i'm
going to tell you all about it i'm
hooked
big brother's back i'm a huge big
brother fan for big brother 24.
there was a small water controversy
this girl with some cultural
appropriation nonsense
and the kardashians are taking 17-minute
flights let's talk about it
[Music]
just the girls
all right y'all welcome back to riffing
with griffin
let's go do not disturb on the phone
uh what's up y'all we back at it back at
it once again oh you know i forgot to do
this man this is like you know i got a
one-man show but welcome to
ricky with griffin
starring eric griffin
make sure you
subscribe share
hit the notifications please tell your
friends
share with everybody check out my
instagram cause i'm putting up some more
videos and stuff every day that has to
do with the podcast i'm putting some
best doves on there and i'm just trying
to grow i need you to help me grow all
of you fun
like loyal followers that i have i
really appreciate you guys so you know
what help me spread the word you know
the more you talk about me on your
social media is telling your friends hey
i really like this guy's podcast check
it out that will help me so i appreciate
that i'm also on twitch if you want to
be a twitch follower you can subscribe
to me on twitch there's so many ways to
help me support the show and the things
that i do if you want to be a part of
twitch you can become go be a twitch
subscriber there that will help or you
could be a member here on youtube you
could do that too or you can also join
me on patreon
where i'm starting to put some of my
gaming videos up there too
i'm gonna just flood that with as much
original you know exclusive content as i
can
on there moving forward so i appreciate
that and you know
again welcome back to
riffin with griffey griffin
and uh shout out to the chat we are live
right now as you know if you're
listening on
uh whatever the the you know you're
you know apple
or
amazon or google mute whatever you
listening on spotify thank you very much
for being uh listening every week too
and then coming over to youtube and
watching there too i'll you know i love
all that so thank you guys help me
spread you know the more if you give me
uh reviews on uh the apple that really
helps push the the algorithm for helping
me out so it's good to put up go on
there and put reviews i guess even good
or bad but
obviously i appreciate a good review
um so do that if you really if you're
here if you're a loyal listener you know
get out there i mean a lot of times
people sit down and they're silent and
they don't want to say anything they
think um you know you know but actually
it does help you know unfortunately it's
all the negative stuff that people hear
about the most you know so it's it's you
know what you don't know how it helps to
have the positive stuff out there too so
you know check that out
um
yeah man so thank you uh you know it's
like you know it's crazy i just want to
talk about something that's real funny
to me you know i still you know ever
since all that bobby brendan and all
that nonsense that went on it's all died
away now but people you know the people
that are the haters and you know because
check me out on my two other podcasts on
gentogen with matthew espinoza check me
out on there and i'm also on king stang
wing and i'm the sing so check me out on
that you know so it's funny how people
still hit me up these like brendan
haters you know they're always like oh
man you're doing it for the check and
all this stuff about the check check
check check the always talk about money
but it's so funny to me is what people
don't understand is
theo
asked me to do the podcast
in the beginning it was always it was
theo
so it's funny that people keep getting
on me about one but they forget the
other it was called king
and the sting
but never
they never talk about the king it's
always the haters or the other which is
kind of stupid to me so i don't know why
you guys keep stop hitting me up about
that and not talking about both
you know what i mean you just seem
stupid but i appreciate my brothers over
there that's that show is so fun to do i
have a good time with theo brendan and
chris and all the crew nick and chen and
mark and all the people that are part of
king and the sting i appreciate them
that's been fun that's been fun to do
because i get to interact with other
people and then i'm over here on my
podcast doing it like this
uh interacting with you guys
um
so yeah the whole thing was bonkers and
so now you know
you know you know exactly uh astro and
the cat in the chat shout out to astro
in the chat
who cares let's move on he's right
let's move on
to
um and if anybody has uh any uh
questions in chat you know i want to
thank the chat for being here live so if
y'all have some uh you know if y'all
have some things in there just put like
in capital letters question for griffin
or at griffin so i could see it
highlighted and then i'll try to like
answer those whenever i can
um
or you know if you send a super chat
actually that's actually even better you
know send a super chat with a question
it'll definitely get answered
um where are we now okay so
all right i got a bunch of stuff i want
to talk about today on the podcast
uh some like more current eventy stuff
um
first up is this thing i saw
it was like
it was about this uh spa water
this
this is like this is like really bizarre
and it just caught my eye and i wanted
to talk about it like what is spa water
what is fresca aqua fresca so just like
um this like influencer
influencers entire career ruined by
misleading mislabeling aqua fresca as
spa water now the internet is deep
diving for people to yell at you know
it's crazy it's like a crazy thing man
so this like influencer is like showing
people how to make spa water i you know
i i guess that's what this is about
so apparently this is some kind of like
mexican thing you know
i don't know
uh it's a you know what is aqua fresca
it's a fruit infused beverage often made
by blending fruit water and sugar this
mexican beverage can be found all over
the u.s and has gained popularity over
the last few decades
it's currently found in many fast food
franchises as well as more authentic
versions that can often be spotted at
fairs farmers markets and restaurants
so
apparently this this like social media
person was showing her recipe and she
was calling it spa water
is that like
first of all
i hate when people immediately make
everything cultural appropriation you
know like just because because
you know it's like i remember talking
about dreadlocks and it's like you see a
white person with dreadlocks and
everybody's like oh man
you're stealing it you're trying to be
black you're you know culture all this
stuff right and then it's as if they
don't know the history of things like
the vikings the white vikings wore
dreadlocks you know what i'm saying so
it's like whatever right this is one of
these things where you go so some dumb
influence influencer who has to come up
with like stuff to talk about like a la
me
i'm talking about dumb too so you
know
she's showing her recipe for and she
called this spa water it just happened
to be the same recipe for
this aqua fresca but it's like
i go to the united airlines lounge
when i go to the
united airlines lounge they got two big
things of water and there'll be some
like lemons and stuff in it and it's
like oh that's just some stuff to make
it you know taste better
is this
are they stealing some recipe you know
what i mean like they just putting it
there you know so when you go to the spa
because they call it spa water because
if you've ever gone to a spa they always
have this you know you got your robe on
you waiting for your masseuse and you in
like some vegas hotel i love the vegas
hotel spas i by the way i used to look i
used to love going to vegas and i would
go by myself i would go midweek i'd fly
into vegas
i you know go to the hotel uh you know i
already got my i signed up for a massage
get the massage spa go get myself a
steak dinner by myself go play some
craps and the next day i would come home
and it would be a way for me to just be
like oh i'm just getting away and just
enjoying myself i used to love to do
that
married now so that's gonna be hard to
do now but you know i would take her
with me right
but um and then anyways at those kind of
spas they always got like spa water
which is probably aqua fresca if you if
they're doing it like this where it's
just like a tub full of like cucumbers
and all kinds of stuff and but the fact
that the fact that like somebody like
people on the internet man they just
looking for people to yell at you know
it's like especially if it's like an
influencer who you've been praising and
and um
uh making famous because of the silly
videos that they put up and then
after a while
you go um you know what they're getting
a little bit too much and we don't like
this thing that they did so let's attack
and tear this person down i mean man
it's such a slippery slope like at what
point at what point is it like this is
too much like leave people alone or or
maybe if you just go does it have to be
like a cancelable offense you know that
just this person was making like what
she called spa water and it just
happened to be like a recipe for this it
would be like claiming cake
you know like hey i made cake oh you
mean flour eggs with some sugar and you
know some whatever you put in some icing
it's like everybody's got their cake
recipe and it's probably all very
similar just to to race to the level
people really need something to do
people need to go out vote and work and
worry about real world issues that are
going on out there as opposed to you
know getting mad at somebody from
for for stealing a shitty recipe for
some like you know flavored water you
know what i mean it's craziness but that
leads me to
that leads me to another like crazy type
story that's in the news
i don't know if it's in the news but
it's like one of these things it's like
the kardashians you know
so
first of all rachel loves the
kardashians she loves it she just loves
all that kind of stuff so she'll be
sitting and watching just glued and i'm
looking at her like why do you like this
you know but it is what it is why do
people like the kardashians it's been on
the air for over 10 years i think 20
years huh i think it's been on the air
for 20 years
so
recently and it's not i think khloe
kardashian also got in trouble for this
um
yeah
kourtney kardashian got in trouble for
this earlier this year but apparently
the kardashians are jumping on their jet
and they're taking short flights
maybe they might go from van nuys to you
know long beach or whatever it is like
that it's like 17-minute flights
20-minute flights and then all these
people are getting on them for being
like you know climate criminals and
these jets should never be allowed to
take like all this kind of stuff
and my thing is like what
you driving a car
are you not why aren't you carpooling
like if you have your car and you
getting putting gas in your car but see
people don't think of it like that they
go well my little bit doesn't matter
every you could help the environment too
by taking public transportation get on a
train if you live in l.a uh you know
what i mean are you doing your part why
is it always the rich people that got to
do
you know everything you know and it's
like
you know i i'm not even
i don't got private jet money trust me
that's why i'm doing my little podcast
if you think i got a lot of money you
you foo you you food but i probably got
more money than the average person right
uh so i i have some things i might
upgrade to first class just because i
can you know
uh
but i'm still flying i got to fly
everywhere i go to to do shows it's not
private but i'm on a jet you know should
i be driving cross-country in my car or
my electric car and taking two weeks to
get places because like you know to
appease these climate people but the
thing that gets me is like
the kardashians have been made famous
by
us
the the youngest ones kylie and
kendall for instance they were little
kids on tv they've been rich and famous
their whole lives
we have built them up we built kylie
jenner up for instance to the point
where now she is a billionaire and she
acted like a billionaire
we've watched it people watch it and
they they see everything that she does
and they're like this is what you want
why else are you watching it how come
the environmentalist family isn't famous
on tv how come they don't have a 200
million dollar deal or however much it
was with hulu to bring their show back
you know what i mean like
the the environmentalist
nobody's watching the environmentalist
reality show because it that's not what
that entertainment is about
it's just crazy to me
to build people up
just to tear them down
you know how they did this to
build somebody up just to tear them down
but boy
justin bieber
okay
poor justin bieber right
he's nine years old just making his
music on the internet trying to just get
some likes and love to show people how
talented he is everybody was like you're
great wow this nine-year-old is so
adorable it's so great he's nine years
old though so he probably was like well
i'm just nine i'm not great i'm great no
i'm nine years old nine ten eleven he
gets to 12 13 he's like what you guys
think i'm great i'm still oh wow am i
great no come on guys i'm 12. i'm 13. 15
16. he was probably like
am i you know what i might be no am i
great maybe i could be they keep saying
it uh maybe not
17 18 19 he was like you know what i'm
great you right everybody you've been
telling me for 10 years i'm great i am
great and that's when we went like this
whoa
whoa buddy tone it down bro
okay
get some humility in your soul man and
then he went off the rails he's like
what are you talking about i'm now a pop
star i got a hundred million dollars and
no parental supervision yeah i'm a pee
in a bucket and i'm gonna buy a tiger
i'm gonna like you know he's he's a
young man he's young with money he's
talented he can't trust anyone
everybody's trying to get something from
him and then we building them up and
then we tear them down so we saw this
kind of rocky road that we put the guy
through and now he's finally like got
himself settled in he's married and
hopefully he's like old enough now he's
almost going to be he's in his mid 20
almost mid 20s but it's like look at the
roller coaster that we put people
through in their lives to me it could be
it's unfair expectations it's unfair
and so we put this on these people
we wanted to we you wanted to see
kendall and kylie
grow up and become
rich and famous like their family
presented it and now when they're doing
it when they acting rich and famous they
doing rich and famous y'all mad
y'all mad at him
what
then then look take away all private
jets then there should be no private
jets but if i have a private jet
i'm gonna use my private jet what we
talking about
people everybody talk about the
environment oh you an environmentalist
all of a sudden everybody talks about
these people that talk about the
environment are you voting uh you know
are you doing your part like i said you
still driving your car oh but of course
you're gonna be like well i have to
drive a car i mean i have to get to work
i have to do things do you are you not
setting up a car pool are you not like
well like what are you doing to help the
environment what are you doing at your
own place you got all the lights on you
know you are you are you know you're
using your washing machine are you
flushing your toilet every single time i
mean they're talking about that you
should you know you shouldn't flush your
toilet every single time you know unless
it's poop you know you got poop in there
you flush it but like you know these
some of these the hardcore
environmentalist type people are like
yeah you should just leave the pee in
there close it and then just ppp and
then flush it after a while are you
doing that why should she be responsible
for for the the all the environment you
know
get your together man get your
together
first of all if you're even the fact
that you even know if you're even
following them on social media to see
the things that they're doing look at
some of the things people are saying
kylie jenner is such a climate criminal
these jets should never be allowed to
take off a climate
criminal
that's where we're going now we're on
that
this one kylie's jenner's stupid private
jets and her stupid and different
attitude to the cost they have on the
environment this stupid attitude that we
gave her
what are you what are we talking about
yeah she living a lavish lifestyle that
she earned
because of us
uh so it's like we want to continue to
do our little thing we want to we want
to you know have our lights on flush our
toilets drive our cars but then the rich
people we want to be like yo
uh
you shouldn't be on a private jet flying
only 17 minutes it has to be super
important when you fly your private jet
no other reason should you fly a private
jet
get the hell
out of here
you know what i mean get out of here
with that
so
i don't know
it's just
it's it's it's bizarre man but i get it
too look i also get like listen we do
have to do better as a society
but this ain't the way that's what i'm
saying attacking
rich and famous people that we made rich
and famous
attacking them
is not the way
i remember having an argument with my
aunt a long time ago i just i remember
this when she was like i was talking
about a particular artist that i liked
this like famous you know singer
whatever right i forgot who it was
though but it could have been like
michael jackson or somebody like that
and then she was like well how much
money
is he giving to charity
you know how much money is he giving to
charity i love this
so i love when people do this so you
want to
buy the records this is what people want
to do
i'm going to twenty dollars for this
album this is back in the day y'all i'm
gonna spend 20 on this album and then i
of that 20 i expect that person to give
money to charity hey
give money to charity why don't you just
give money to charity you know do you
need that album you know it's
it's it's like a it's a bananas thought
process that we have
where
you know we want to just have it our way
and then we expect these other people to
be the ones to take care of the world's
problems when we're sitting here not
doing our own part
uh
you know you know you know what are you
doing
all right so i see people trying to
write questions in the chat real quick
so let's just go to that right now
or see one here this this one looks
stupid though
you know i'm live so
what do you think about people sitting
in their pjs for hours just to make it a
tax write-off
they need a certain amount of business
hours to make it a business expense
hey man you know and that's from ryan
fagan
you know what this is like
it's like
unfortunately
you have laws that are set up
to try to get like so the government has
set up laws and restrictions and things
to try to get as much tax money out of
people as possible and the people that
are there
the people they're trying to
pay
at least amount as they can within the
rules in the system
and so it's just a give and take a back
and forth between
you know what's right what's wrong and
what we think is acceptable
and so you know
it is what it is
you know i mean but i listen if you have
your own personal i remember another
friend of mine oh god rest his soul it's
a comic and he he passed away
uh sadiki fuller i remember
i remember this about siddiqui phil it
was a funny comic uh he used to be
he used to be a nba mascot so he was v
he was an acrobat you know and he became
a comic and he used to do a backflip on
stage all the time and all the comics we
used to tease him about it because it
was so you know what i mean comics are
so like anytime like a comic has a skill
that they don't have they they try to
trash that skill you know it happens to
me all the time like i could sing so if
i sing on stage these like you
know pseudo uh you know comics comics
are like oh you're singing on stage or
if i if i do sound effects or i use
things in my skill set to make people to
entertain people all of a sudden that's
frowned upon by the people who like they
think they're like traditional joke
tellers you know what i mean and i say
to them you ain't better than me i
could tell jokes just as good as you all
right if not better and i also can sing
i also can do sound effects i also can
like be boisterous and entertaining i
can do act outs just because you don't
have that skill set sorry homie work on
your game all right but don't think
because you're standing there just oh
i'm telling though i'm being smart right
now hey look at my face off all
right that's what i say to people like
that those kind of would be like you
know
oh this is how comic the comedy police
eat it
anyways
i remember i was having a conversation
with my boy
and he he used to be a oh he was a weed
smoker man he's like go at it with the
weed
right so then i remember we were having
this conversation one day and he was
like man i don't have health care
and he was like i might move to canada
he was just joking around but we were
having a serious conversation you know
he was like yeah man i uh
um
[Music]
you know
he was like yeah i can't you know i
can't afford health insurance i don't
even have cable you know and then i
remember asking him i said hey man
how much money a month would you say
you spend on weed
and it was something like
250 to 300
and i was like that sounds like
good health care and a premium package
at uh you know cable
so it really comes to choices
so when people come to talk about
that they can't do this and they can't
do that just make sure you got all your
ducks in a row before you start
complaining about what other people have
or what the cost of things are
life is about choices man there are
people out there who are struggling they
can't really can't afford stuff then
there's other people who just feel
entitled and think they deserve
everything you know what i mean so
anyways
i went on a tangent i don't even know
what i'm talking about anymore
all right
let's go to
uh
let's go to something else now you know
let's go quick fast episode about stuff
i want to talk about this now man i
i know
you guys have heard me talk about this
on other podcasts and my own podcast i
don't like combat sports
i do not like combat sports
i just it just oof i have friends
who fight in who fought in the ufc who
were currently fighting in the ufc and i
hate seeing it i hate seeing them
getting beat up i hate you know it's
just it's something like barbaric about
it
but
brendan
schaab had me be on his fight companion
and i watched brendan's fights all his
losses
and it was interesting to see
him talk about it and and him saying how
he wasn't prepared at some and you know
he just it just
i felt like he was mismanaged by his
management he shouldn't have fought some
of the fights he fought but it made me
start to see that there's more to it
than just the barbarism of it if that's
even a word about the actual fights
themselves
and so we did this other fight thing and
you could catch that on youtube you know
catch that on youtube right now man um
[Music]
about on the on thick boy youtube about
is him and i talking about patty to
batty
and
the dude's fascinating man like shout
out to this dude uh
he got that thing man i don't know what
it is but he got that thing it reminds
me the only only other time i can
compare to because for me being
interested in it was when ronda rousey
had her rise you know like everybody was
talking about her it was like oh my gosh
she's the mike tyson of you know and it
was just like really like adam wasn't
into it i didn't i don't like seeing
women fight you know what i mean i just
there's something about women getting
bashed in the face and you see the blood
i don't like it and you know sure enough
you know she had this
like historic rise it brought all this
attention to the ufc and then she just
got demolished twice
and then so that so i think that
so now the ufc is i think trying to
make sure they bring this guy along
slowly but he's a star man he's from
london he's got like you know his fans
love him and he's charismatic you know
he does this little weird dance every
time he goes in the ring and then he
just locks in he's an attractive dude
he's got a weird haircut you know
obviously he's in he's in shape
you know what i'm saying he's like you
know and he's got that fierce so i'm
watching this fight for the first time
after watching three of his fights
on the companion show
and i was like and i get interested i
really like hearing brendan talk about
fighting and because i have no i don't
know anything about there's like
technical things there's like some guys
can box some guys can grapple some guys
are good at jujitsu some guys are you
know so you got the kickers and the
punchers and the and the people that
know how to like get you in these like
you know submission holds and it's like
it's so very fascinating to see all the
different aspects of ufc fighting so
this guy you know he's had his rise so
now he finally had a couple of ufc
fights i think this was his first really
big fight against this guy
and you can tell that they were both
prepared so what little knowledge i have
of fighting i'm learning about it you
know from watching and hearing the
people talking and having a new
fascination for it so the one guy so
patty's great at obviously he's great at
fighting you know he he's like a good
boxer apparently you know he got the
good he got hands he know how to throw
hands and so this guy he was fighting he
knows that so he was trying to get and
keep him
locked in close and try to like get him
in the hold
and you could tell that patty was
prepared for that he countered and it
was it was like that the technical side
of it
opened up to me and i saw it from more
than just this sort of barbaric two men
beating each other it became like a
thing of like wow this is an amazing set
of skills that both these guys possess
and they are trying to find the weakness
in the other
and accentuate their own strengths and
it was
it was an incredible fight for such a
short fight
and paddy got him and i found myself you
know when he got him in the submission
hold i was like oh my god i felt like i
felt like yes i was like so excited for
him so
the dude's a star man
the dude's a star i think he's got that
thing
and i i hope that he uh you know he
needed this last fight
from what i see is like it was an
important fight for him to win to really
establish his lore his legacy to like
let people put the ufc on notice that i
am here i am bigger than all of you type
of vibe he's putting out you know he got
that people say he's got that mcgregor
thing but like mcgregor to me was always
like a villain i think he there was a
certain time that he switched it and he
was like i want to be the villain he
reminds me of ric flair you know he just
wants to be like hated and people loved
to hate him but then mcgregor went off
the rails man in terms of you know he's
throwing
dollies at buses and you know he just it
just got i think it got away from him
but this guy seems to have that hero
thing where you like you want him to
succeed
so
it's uh
it's um
it it's it's interesting you know and
then yes and thank you
leonardo rodriguez
and then patty went out of his way to
take the mic
and talk about his uh i believe it was
his friend another fighter who who uh
sadly took his own life and then he took
some time to talk about uh you know
having the proper mind state and and
mental health
and you know it's like the guy the kids
got that thing he's so present he's so
aware of his stardom he's so aware of
how important it is the things that he
says and how he carries himself and i
just think that it's like a good you
know what a good role model for somebody
who like you know if you're into
fighting and you want to fight i think
patty the baddies the the real deal man
dude's the real deal and like i'm a fan
you know he got me to watch ufc he's got
me to talk about it in this way and so i
have to just uh you know
find my find a way now to like you know
learn more about it i mean there is
times when i'm just like ooh that was
tough to watch
but um
you know
even the fight before that one the fight
before that um god i forgot who was
fighting but just to like see like the
techno guy like he was like pat pal then
swung around with an elbow i was like
god damn this is tough you know but you
can start to like appreciate
the skills
you know you can appreciate like when
you take a step back from it like i said
when you can distance yourself from the
barbarism of
you know what i mean the barbaric nature
of combat sports but there is something
really special about
uh when you start to understand you know
the grappling
uh the different martial arts
the boxing and then
the kicking and how to use that
um you know to your advantage based off
what the other person is good at or bad
at and this guy seems to like have that
he got it so shout out to his team
because he looked he was
so prepared for this fight
so shout out to
his team shout out to patty for just
representing and being a great
representation of all you know also
you know that league he came from in
europe and to try to like you know
come bring that over to the ufc and and
dominate take it over
so
we'll see man um
you know it's you know it's weird when
you're watching the ufc so i don't know
who won oh man there was a freak
accident in the in the main card right
the big black dude in the other guy
you know it's like i was watching when
you watch the highlight package of a
fighter
um
when you talk about the the highlight
package of a fighter man and you see it
there's something about
you you kind of you you kind of get a
sense like damn can this guy be beat
you know what i mean
like i don't know what what's the name
of that dude man the the the
the the main guy that i forgot his name
man i wish i'm never prepared but the
the the ferocious heavyweight black dude
that was in that fight with patty the
the main card and the other dude you
know freakishly tore his acl or
something i don't know who that guy was
but man i i i didn't think that guy was
going to be able to uh blades curtis
blades thank you
blades i saw blades highlight package
and i was like i don't think anybody's
gonna be able to beat this guy you know
what i mean just like but of course
they're only showing the best you know
but it just looked like damn
i was like i would not want to meet this
dude in the dark alley and if he was
trying to take my wallet because i'd be
like take my wallet sir
it was uh and then he was fighting that
other guy and what was the other guy's
name and i believe that like that guy
had a freakish accident and so then
there was no contest or i believe they
gave the win the blades and i wouldn't
want to win like that but you know it is
what it is you know people get hurt in
other sports and they don't go let's run
it back next year you know they don't do
that you know it's like you know what if
like the golden state warriors and the
cuban claviers they were like well kevin
love and kyrie irving got hurt so we're
going to put this championship on hold
until they're better and then we're
going to play when everybody's at full
strength you know they don't do it like
that
you know they don't do it like that so
i'm just so interested to see like
this i'm like listen man i'm a ufc
virgin i'm not going to pretend like i
know what i'm talking about you know i'm
going to use your guys's um um
aspinall that's right tom aspen i'm
going to use your guys's help you know
when you guys send me comments in the
chat we're just trying to learn about it
i don't need the negative comments
talking about oh this i don't know what
he's talking about i freely admit i
don't know what i'm talking about and
i'm interested in learning it's a very
new it's a very new thing for me and uh
you know it's interesting to see what
these fighters
you know it's i i like i like the idea
of
like
what is this fighter good at and then
what is the other fighter good at and
let's see how this mixes because i hear
max kellerman on all the time the sports
sports guy
he says all the time styles make fights
and when i watch this paddy fight i
really clicked in and understood exactly
what they mean by that styles make
fights
i get it now you know and it's like can
you adjust your style for this fight
and patty
did that got the submission
it was great
um and i look forward to see the guy's
future i hope i get to talk to him
through brendan you know having whatever
he because he already had him on his
food truck diaries i would love to i
just want to pick the dude's brain man
and talk to him about fighting and like
you know you know
it's just interesting he's an
interesting dude and uh you know i wish
him all the best with that so that's my
patty the baddie segment i hope you guys
enjoyed
that um all right let's get to
[Music]
what else i got here oh
already talked about this one oh here's
this one all right
all right last one last but not least
big
brother
i absolutely love big brother
so get you ready for a lot of big
brother segments coming up on riffing
with griffin
sorry i just took a drink i know that's
probably terrible for the people that
are listening
this is probably like some weird asmr
just every time i drink you guys know
what asmr is it's like that you know
what people go
that's what it sounds like
anyway
i love big brother okay
i love big brother so let's go over what
big brother is for people that don't
know what big brother is
big brother is a reality competition
show where
16 people let's see one two three four
one two three four five yeah it's like
16 people whatever how many that is one
thing
yeah it's like 16 people
they go into a house
they're locked in they're filmed 24
hours a day
and there's
different competitions
okay
there's different competitions thank you
ryan for the super chat different
competitions
that uh they compete against and then
they vote each other out of the house
till there's only two people left and
then the winner gets 750 000
now what i like about big brother it's
like a super duper psychological
experiment
because what ends up happening is you
have to form alliances and you also have
to break those alliances you have to lie
and cheat and and you have to like you
know make friendships that aren't real
because you're trying to get this money
so it really does bring at times the
worst out of people
now for years big brother was usually 16
hot people okay
hot athletic young people
coming to the house and they're doing
endurance competitions
they're doing a lot of like
you know
running around a lot of like stuff that
you should be in shape to do it a lot of
pretty people cut to
hollywood is all into this like well we
have to include people it has to be
inclusion and we have to do this and
that so then they started like at first
it was about like race so it was like 16
hot people it'd be hot mexicans hot
black hot asian hot white it was a lot
of hot it's still hot which it still
should be in my opinion because it's a
reality show it's entertainment we want
to see hot people doing hot people stuff
and we want to see hot people being
terrible that's what we like watching
you know what i mean it's like it's like
housewives we watch you know and then
and then we see the worst in these
people so then they started to go well
we need more types of people so they
started allowing nerds
and fat people and old people
i got a problem with this okay
i got a problem and it ain't about not
being anti-inclusion
you can't just have inclusion for
inclusion's sake for instance
if we're talking about say
i'm looking for somebody to do the 100
yard dash
i inclusion don't matter here it's about
having people with the ability to
complete and race well in this hundred
yard dash what type of people are that's
gonna be it's gonna be
athletic people okay so
on big brother
i
you don't have any fat girls on big
brother right before why because you're
doing athletic stuff why set them up for
failure because that's what they were
doing
and i i had a problem with it because
they weren't changing the competitions
because sometimes it's endurance and
athletic and other times it's about
mental stuff right so that could be
anybody which i liked but in the end it
was always somebody
athletic it was always somebody you know
you know what i mean because that's the
nature of it
so then i remember one year three two
three years ago they had this fat girl
she's on like it's an endurance
competition where she has to hold on to
a rope and she has to hold and so all 16
people are on a rope and whoever is the
last person on the rope wins
they cut to the fat girl
she on this rope struggling and you hear
the voiceover of her saying
i just want to show all the girls out
there who look like me that we can do it
and then she falls and they show that on
tv and i'm like of course she's going to
fall like you're setting her up for
failure don't show me freaking inclusion
and then have all the competitions be
something that a fat girl can't do it's
just that frustrates me that people but
these dumb
sensitive woke idiots that's all they
care about they just go we need to see
inclusion on this show it's like no you
don't no you don't know because you're
setting this person up for failure all
right cut to this year
cut to this year
and i think i gotta hand it to big
brother
they actually found a way
so they had this endure they had a
two-part competition it was this
obstacle course
and the obstacle course
you had to
run on the thing you know you needed to
be a little athletic so
they were picking people random
by the way
fat
nerds
um old people too remind me old people
i'm only like 40 plus not athletic
people they got them in there too
embarrassing themselves okay before so
now
this is competition i'm a little i'm one
episode behind on the show so they so
there's a there's a chubby girl she's
pretty but i'm just describing because
that's what i'm talking about right now
she a fat girl okay it is what it is all
right calorically challenged however you
want to say it she a fat girl all right
she's going up against this old guy she
beats the old guy and i'm like okay good
for her
she's on the damn obstacle course and
then
when she gets off the ostrich obstacle
course just walking back she trips and
sprains her ankle and i'm like here we
go this is what i'm talking about right
here you know what i'm saying it's like
okay
but it was a two-parter which i
appreciated
they had the obstacle course and then
the second part of the competition was a
pie eating contest
guess who won
[Laughter]
they didn't actually have to eat the pie
but but they had to put their face in
the pie and and you know find some stuff
in the pot they had to find objects in
this big old pie but
y'all
guess who won the pie eating contest
so i was like
oh big brother did it they found a
way to have it both ways athletic and
then they have something where somebody
who
you know can't really run fast and jump
high they got something for them too but
we'll see how it plays out
we will see how it plays out man but i
gotta tell you man that it just
when i was it i was
dying laughing when i saw
first she goes on the obstacle course
and then completes it and then sprains
her ankle just walking and i was like oh
my god i totally i understand that
because my fat ass has sprained my ankle
just walking
too many times to count so i was like i
feel you girl i know your pain but then
when they sat her at the table for the
pie eating contest and she
i was like okay you know what big
brother you heard me
you heard me and you followed through
and that's
[Laughter]
oh my god that's how they did it so i
just thought
i just thought oh man what else are they
gonna do this season so i'm looking
forward to it but you will hear me talk
about big brother a lot you know
because it's just so crazy to
i love all the intrigue i love all the
infighting i love all the like the lies
and the in the manipulating and the
scheming to see who's gonna end up the
winner then and they raised it from 500
000 to 250 750 000 so that's pretty cool
so i like again if you love big brother
you're gonna you're gonna hear about it
if you don't love big brother you still
gonna hear about it so this is how we
gonna do it
uh
all right guys
um once again uh this has been griffin
with griffin again make sure you
subscribe
you know um
hit the notifications and please share
you know and again you can catch me on
twitch now as you know at the end of
every episode now we doing
we're doing this new thing i like to
call it
the this this this is the
the the uh
the rap wrap up we're doing the wrap
wrap up and once again my boy chris you
you know i put his instagram up last
week but chris you sent me some more
dope beats y'all so we gotta go with
another chris you beat to end it all
okay
wrap up wrap up
griffin
uh with griffin we did it
what we talk about this week
and move your feet
do it well
eric griffin feelings well
you know what i think that was the beat
from last week that beat so good though
let me get one of his new beats
[Applause]
chris you new beat
here we go
bringing it back once again
tell your friend
this is how we do it nice
every question
don't gotta say it twice
[Music]
extra spice
eric griffin
[Music]
[Applause]
kylie jenner taking private jets
everybody's in france texts
oh
that was a short beat
and i was jamming let's go to his next
beat
his other beat oh yeah
[Music]
we doing all the chris you beat on the
wrap-up show today
what else we got
oh yeah
[Music]
patty patty
i'm so glad
he ain't no fatty
don't be sad he's at it
ufc
eric griffin
that's about me
[Music]
thanks for watching thanks for listening
thanks for i got you
send them super chats
so eric you can do them raps
[Laughter]
oh whatever i think we recapped
everything